the next stage is you know is to be a
great delegator and not try and do
everything yourself try to find people
who are better than you all the time
trying to find people are better than
you to put you put you out of business
effectively so you know whatever you're
spending all your day doing try to find
someone who's better than you to do that
to replace you at it so that you know
you can go off and you know think about
the next big picture you know an
entrepreneur it's not a man I'm not a
manager I mean an entrepreneur somebody
who is great at conceiving ideas
starting and starting ideas built
building ideas but then handing over to
really good managers to manage the
businesses you know the moment you've
got more than one business you can't be
hands-on doing everything I don't
actually think we're the stereo the
stereotype of a business person
shredding away over people to get to the
top
generally speaking works I think if you
treat people well people will come back
and and come back for more and it's a
very small world I actually think that
the you know the bet the best wave of
becoming a successful business leader is
is it's dealing with people you know
fairly and and well and like to think
that's how how we run virgin you just
watched two amazing clips with Sir
Richard Branson take the next three
minutes and sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]